>> I AM DANA PERINO WITH JUAN
WILLIAMS AND JESSE WATTERS AND
GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5 O'CLOCK IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> MAJORS REVELATIONS FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR ABOUT HOW
THE RUSSIA PROBE STARTED.
IN HIS FIRST INTERVIEW SINCE THE
MUELLER REPORT WAS RELEASED,
BARR IS NOT SATISFIED ON THE
ANSWERS ABOUT TRUMP CAMPAIGN
SPYING.
>> I AM TRYING TO GET ANSWERS TO
QUESTIONS.
A LOT OF THE ANSWERS HAVE BEEN
INADEQUATE AND SOME OF THE
EXPLANATIONS I GOT DON'T HANG
TOGETHER.
IN A SENSE, I HAVE MORE
QUESTIONS TODAY THAN WHEN I
FIRST STARTED.
PEOPLE HAVE TO FIND OUT WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT WAS DOING DURING THAT
PERIOD.
IF WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT FOREIGN
INFLUENCE, WE SHOULD WORRY
WHETHER GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
ABUSED THEIR POWER AND PUT THEIR
THUMB ON THE SCALE.
I AM NOT SAYING THAT HAPPENED.
BUT I AM SAYING WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THAT.
>> BARR COMMENTING ON THE STEELE
DOSSIER.
>> IT'S AN UNUSUAL SITUATION TO
HAVE OPPOSITION RESEARCH LIKE
THAT, ESPECIALLY ONE THAT ON ITS
FACE HAD A NUMBER OF CLEAR
MISTAKES AND TO USE THAT TO
CONDUCT COUNTER-INTELLIGENCE
AGAINST AMERICAN POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN WOULD BE A STRANGE
DEVELOPMENT.
I AM NOT SURE WHAT ROLE IT
PLAYED.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT.
>> GREG, I HAVE A THEORY.
MY THEORY IS THAT IF YOU WERE IN
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AT THE
TIME OF THE 2016 ELECTION AND
YOU WERE AWARE OF RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE, IT WOULD SEEM YOU
WOULD WELCOME AN INVESTIGATION
INTO THE INVESTIGATION.
>> ABSOLUTELY!
BUT YOU MAY HAVE HEARD A PHRASE
I COINED:
WHAT IS GOOD FOR THE GOOSE IS
GOOD FOR THE --
>> THE GANDER.
>> NO FOR MY UNCLE STEVE.
>> HOW IS HE DOING?
>> I FEED HIM LETTUCE AND
INSECTS LIKE A GOOSE.
THE DEMS HAVE SPENT 2 YEARS
DOING THIS.
DO YOU THINK THEY WILL JUST LET
IT GO?
YOU COULD USE THE SAME ARGUMENT.
WE KNOW THAT THE RUSSIANS TRIED
TO MEDDLE.
NOW WE NEED TO KNOW WHO HELPED
THEM.
IT'S THE SAME ARGUMENT IN
REVERSE.
THE GREAT DOSSIER IS LIKE A BAD
PATCH OF EGG SALAD AND EVERYBODY
GOT FOOD POISONING.
THAT'S WHY CNN IS RED IN THE
FACE.
>> CNN IS NOT MAD.
IF YOU WERE LIED TO BY THE OBAMA
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS FOR 2
YEARS AND THEY HUMILIATED YOU,
WOULDN'T YOU WANT TO KNOW HOW
AND WHY THAT YOU WERE LIED TO?
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY HAVE NO
INTEREST IN FINDING OUT WHAT
WENT WRONG WITH THE COLLUSION
HOAX?
THE STEELE DOSSIER AND THE FISA
WARRANT, WE ARE LEARNING MORE.
THE FISA WARRANT ON LISA PAGE
WAS BASED OFF THE STEELE
DOSSIER.
A RED FLAG IN THE STEELE DOSSIER
SAID THEY WERE RUNNING THIS
OPERATION THROUGH CARTER PAGE
OUT OF THE RUSSIAN EMBASSY IN
MIAMI.
THERE IS NO RUSSIAN EMBASSY IN
IN TAMPA.
THE OTHER 2 REASONS FOR THE
WARRANT, 2 MEETINGS THAT CARTER
PAGE HAD WITH THE RUSSIANS
OLIGARCHS.
BOTH MEETINGS NEVER HAPPENED AND
THEY USED A YAHOO NEWS ARTICLE.
THEN YOU HAVE PAPADOPOULOS.
WE ARE LEARNING THIS IS WHAT NOT
STARTED OFF THE ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION.
HE NEVER SPOKE TO A RUSSIAN.
WE HAVE TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN
STRZOK AND PAGE WHO CALLED
MISFUD WHO STARTED THIS WHOLE
THING THEIR GUY.
IF HE IS A RUSSIAN AGENT HOW IS
HE THEIR GUY?
>> IF I CAN CONTINUE ON WITH MY
THEORY.
IF YOU ARE HILLARY CLINTON AND
YOU BELIEVE THIS ELECTION WAS
STOLEN FROM YOU BECAUSE THE
RUSSIAN INTERFERED, IF YOU
BELIEVE THAT'S TRUE AND THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION DID THE
RIGHT THING, WOULDN'T IT BE A
GOOD THING FOR HER ARGUMENT FOR
THE PEOPLE TO BE SEE WHAT THE
ORIGINS OF THE INVESTIGATION
WERE?
>> RIGHT BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT IS
GOING ON.
WHAT IS GOING ON IS AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE
INVESTIGATORS AS PUNISHMENT
COMING FROM AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT IS OVERWHELMING POLITICAL.
THEY ARE DISTRACTING FROM THE
REAL NEWS THIS WITH SILLINESS.
WE WILL SOON HE TRANSCRIPTS OF
WHAT MICHAEL FLYNN'S LAWYERS
SAID TO TRUMP'S LAWYERS.
LISTENING TO BILL BARR HE HAS NO
REASON TO DO ANYTHING.
HE SAYS, LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT
THE SPYING.
I KNOW I SAID THAT EARLIER.
WHAT ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN
THE TIME TRUMP WAS ELECTED AND
THE TIME HE TAKES OFFICE.
LET'S LOOK AT THE FBI
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES TALKING TO
TRUMP AND TRUMP TOWER.
DID THEY LEAK SOMETHING?
HE JUST CHANGES THE GAME TIME
AND AGAIN.
THAT'S WHY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
FOX NEWS POLL THAT CAME OUT
YESTERDAY, IT SAYS 45% OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT BARR IS
COVERING UP FOR TRUMP AND NOT
BEING TRANSPARENT.
THEY GIVE HIM A NEGATIVE RATING
FOR HOW HE HANDLED THE MUELLER
REPORT.
44% SAY THEY DON'T APPROVE OF
WHAT HE HAS DONE WITH THE
MUELLER REPORT.
>> IF THAT MAKES YOU FEEL BETTER
IT HAS NO EFFECT ON ANYTHING.
IT'S A POLL.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT
BEING HOOD WINKED BY A GUY WHO
IS NOW TRUMP'S LAWYER.
THIS IS WHAT TRUMP WISHED FOR
ALL ALONG.
HE WANTED A ATTORNEY GENERAL --
>> LIKE HOLDER WAS.
THE RUSSIAN STORY IS NOW INTO
SUMMER RERUNS.
I SAW IT ON THE FIRST RUN.
I DON'T NEED TO SEE IT AGAIN.
I KNOW WHAT THE FLYNN STORY IS
ABOUT.
THE ECONOMY IS GOING WELL.
THE WORLD IS PEACEFUL.
THEY HAVE TO KEEP DOING THE
RUSSIAN STORY.
>> GREG, DON'T LOOK HERE!
>> WE ALREADY LOOKED FOR 2
YEARS.
NOW WE ARE LOOKING IN THE OTHER
DIRECTION.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE TALKING POINT
IS THIS INVESTIGATION IS DONE.
NO OBSTRUCTION AND NO COLLUSION.
NADLER HAS SAID THAT.
>> I HAVE A POINT ABOUT THAT.
FIRST LET'S HEAR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ABOUT THE IDEA OF
DESTROYING THE DOCUMENTS AND
CONTEMPT.
>> IT'S PART OF THE USUAL
POLITICAL CIRCUS BEING PLAYED
OUT.
IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME.
>> THE HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI BELIEVES YOU LIED UNDER
OATH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT
CHARGE?
>> IT'S A LAUGHABLE CHARGE.
IT'S LARGELY BEING MADE TO
DISCREDIT ME.
PARTLY BECAUSE THEY MAY BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE OUTCOME OF A
REVIEW OF WHAT HAPPENED DURING
THE ELECTION.
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO DISCREDIT
HIM BECAUSE THEY ARE WORRIED,
PEOPLE WHO WORKED IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND THE FBI AND
CIA, THEY ARE WORRIED.
BRENNAN OR COMEY.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT WHAT BILL
BARR AND JOHN DURHAM AND THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WILL FIND.
HILLARY CLINTON IS QUIET BECAUSE
THE DNC AND THE HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN PAID FOR THAT DOSSIER.
THE WHOLE MUELLER REPORT
DISCREDITS BIG ELEMENT THAT WERE
IN THAT DOSSIER.
I WANT TO POINT THIS OUT.
JIM COMEY LOOKED AT BRET BEHAR
LAST YEAR AND SAID I CAN'T SAY I
KNOW THAT THE STEELE DOSSIER WAS
PAID FOR BY THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
HE WAS RUNNING THE FBI AND HE
DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
THAT'S HOG WASH.
WE ALL KNOW IT.
I ALSO READ THAT POLL, JUAN.
HERE'S WHAT PEOPLE SAID.
A MAJORITY.
58% THINK IT'S AT LEAST SOMEWHAT
LIKELY THE FBI BROKE THE LAW
WHEN IT STARTED INVESTIGATION
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THEY DESERVE ANSWERS.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH A
THOROUGH LOOK AT IT.
>> THEY HAD A THOROUGH LOOK.
WHAT WE ARE DOING NOW IS TRYING
TO PUNISH THE INVESTIGATORS.
>> MUELLER DIDN'T LOOK AT IT!
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> I READ THE WHOLE MUELLER
REPORT.
HE DID NOT LOOK AT THE
INVESTIGATORS.
>> YOU DON'T NEED MUELLER.
PICK UP A NEWSPAPER.